the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi welcome once again to our calculus
revisited lecture where today we shall
discuss the concept of infinitesimals a
rather elusive but very important
concept and because most textbooks
illustrate this topic in terms of
approximations our topic today will be
called approximations and
infinitesimally now how shall we
introduce our subject in terms of topics
that you may be more familiar with
perhaps the easiest way is to go back to
an elementary algebra course to distance
rate and time problems when one talked
about distance equaling rate times time
the question of course is what rate do
you use if the rate is not constant you
see the question of distance equals rate
times time presupposes that you are
dealing with a constant rate now what
does this mean and how is it directly
connected with the development of our
calculus course this shall be the
subject of our investigation today see
the idea is this let's consider the
curve y equals f of X and let's suppose
that the curve is smooth that is that it
possesses a derivative say at the point
x equals x1 let's draw the tangent line
to the curve at x equals x1 now the idea
is this in general what we investigate
in the calculus course is the concept
known as Delta Y Delta Y geometrically
is what it's how much Y has changed
along the curve with respect to X it
turns out that there is a simpler thing
that we could have computed notice if we
look at this particular diagram that
since the tangent line never changes its
slope and by the way when I say tangent
line I mean at the point x1 that once we
leave the point x1 the tangent line in a
way no longer resembles the curve but
the point that is important is I can
compute the change in Y
I to the tangent line here very easily
and the reason for this you see is
rather apparent namely the slope of the
tangent line is on the one hand Delta Y
10 divided by Delta X Delta Y 10 divided
by Delta X on the other hand by
definition of slope the slope of the
line L is also equal to what its dy/dx
it's dy DX evaluated at the point of the
value x equals x1 you see in general the
slope of the curve varies from point to
point so when we talk about the tangent
line we must emphasize at what point on
the curve we've drawn the tangent line
at any rate from this particular diagram
it is not difficult to see that the
compute the change in Y to the tangent
line that this is nothing more than what
dy DX evaluated at x equals x1 times
Delta X and you see this is not an
approximation this is precisely this is
precisely the value of Delta Y 10 the
approximation seems to be when we say
let Delta Y 10 let Delta y 10 represent
Delta Y in other words we get the
intuitive feeling that as Delta X gets
small the difference between the true
Delta Y and Delta Y tan also gets small
another way of saying this is what our
intuitive feeling is that in a
neighborhood of the point of tangency
the tangent line serves as a good
approximation to the curve itself now
let's see what this means in terms of a
specific example I've taken the liberty
of computing the cube of 4.01
in advance it turns out to be sixty four
point four eight one 201 and it's sort
of arbitrary that I pick you business if
there's
if this doesn't look messy enough for
you we could have taken this to the
sixth power and then we could have
squared this but that part is irrelevant
a simple check shows that more or less
this will be a correct statement and
what I would like to do you see is
simply illustrate what our earlier
comments mean in terms of this specific
example let's suppose I wanted to find
an approximation for 4.01 fairly rapidly
the idea is this what I do know is one
number that's very easy to cube which is
near 4.0 one is for itself in other
words I know that 4 cubed is 64 and by
the way I've deliberately drawn this
slightly distorted according to scale so
that we can see what's happening over
here
what 64 point 4 8 1 2 or 1 represents is
the actual change in height from here to
here along the curve in other words it
would be the length of the segment
joining the point P to the point Q here
what I claim is that if I instead try to
find the length of PR the change in Y
not along the curve but along the line
tangent to the curve at the point 4
comma 64 this is what I can find
fairly rapidly in other words what I am
going to do is to work this same idea
here with the special case you see I'm
going to take X 1 to equal 4 and Delta X
to be 0.01 now you see the curve is y
equals x cubed from this I can compute
dy/dx rather quickly now I don't want
dy/dx at any old point I want to compute
it when X is 4 so I can find the slope
of the line L
and when X is 4 this of course simply is
what 4 squared is 16 times 3 is 48 so
what do I have I have that the slope is
48 I also have that Delta X is 0.01 so
according to my recipe Delta Y 10 is
what it's dy DX evaluated at x equals 4
which is 48 times Delta X which is 0.001
and that's point 4 8 see again let's
just stretch the position these two all
I have done now is computed this recipe
in the particular example of trying to
find the cube of 4.01
and you see now notice that this point 4
8 is exactly the length of the of the
accented line here it's the length of PR
and what we do know is that the height
from the x-axis to R is now exactly what
well it's the 64 plus the point 4 8 this
then is our approximation and notice
that this compares with what the precise
answer which is 64 point four eight one
201 in other words notice what a small
error we happen to have in this
particular case and this is the way the
subject is usually brought up it is a it
is not a very important thing from my
point of view in other words I think
it's rather easy to see that first of
all this approximation is rather
nebulous in the sense that it requires a
knowledge of how fast the tangent line
is separating from the curve and this is
a rather difficult topic in its own
right and secondly this was a rather
simple example and we had the luxury
here you see of being able to find the
exact answer so we could compare our
approximation with the exact answer in
many cases it is difficult or impossible
to find the exact answer to emphasize
this more abstractly and more generally
but
consider the following instead of trying
to find the the cube of 4.01 the
generalization here is what that we
could take the curve y equals x cubed
the derivative of Y with respect to X
would then be three x squared evaluated
at an arbitrary point x equals x1 we
would get three X sub 1 squared
in which case Delta Y 10 would be 3 X 1
squared times Delta X could we have
computed the exact value of Delta Y had
we wished and the answer of course is
yes namely what is the exact value of
Delta Y well we want to compute this
between x equals x1 plus Delta X well
what is the value of y when x is x1 plus
Delta X its x1 plus Delta X cubed then
we subtract off x1 cubed and if we
expand this watch what happens by the
binomial theorem we get an x1 cubed term
here which cancels with the x1 cubed
term over here then we get what a 3 x1
squared Delta X so using the binomial
theorem here and then what else do we
get we get plus 3 x1 Delta x squared
plus Delta X cubed and you see what I'd
like to have us view over here is if we
look at just this much of the answer if
we look at just this much of the answer
this part here is precisely what we saw
to be delta y-tan before see this is
Delta Y 10 and what's left over is the
difference of course between delta y-tan
and Delta Y after our Delta Y is just
delta y-tan plus this portion here and
now if you look at this particular
portion over here observe that as we
expected what the size of this thing is
depends both on where we're measuring x1
and also on how big the
size of the interval is namely Delta X
and notice something that we're going to
come back through here notice that the
Delta X Factor here appears at least to
the second power in other words notice
over here that as Delta X gets small
both of these terms get small very
rapidly because you see when Delta X is
close to zero the square of a number
close to zero is even closer to zero but
you see the important thing for now is
to notice that this is the error in
approximating Delta Y by Delta Y 10 and
that this is this error depends both on
X Y and Delta X and the question is can
we state that in a little bit more of a
mathematical language the answer of
course is that we can in particular what
we're saying is let's take the
difference between dydx at x equals x1
namely the slope of the tangent line and
what the average change of Y with
respect to X is along the curve now this
is very typical in mathematics and it's
a very nice trick to learn and a very
quick trick to learn we know that these
two things are not equal and so all we
do is is tack on a correction factor we
tack on K what is K K is the difference
between these two expressions in other
words by definition I add on the
difference of these two numbers and that
makes this an equality notice by the way
that K is a variable it depends on how
big Delta X is you see notice that once
x1 is chosen once x1 is chosen and this
is an important observation as messy as
this thing looks it's a fixed number for
a particular value of x1 namely we
compute the derivative and evaluate it
when x equals x1 this is a number this
of course clearly depends on the size of
Delta X Delta Y depends on Delta X at
any rate here's what we do we recognize
that the Y DX is the limit of Delta Y
over Delta X as Delta X approaches zero
so what this is a hint we let we take
the limit of both sides here as
the X approaches zero now you see this
is notice the structure again in our
last series of lectures we talked about
limit theorems we talked about the limit
of a sum being the sum of the limits
things of this type and now you see
we're going to use these results what we
do is is we take the limit of both sides
here as Delta X approaches zero okay
the point being what that the limit of a
sum is the sum of the limits so when I
take the limit of this entire side I can
express that as the limit the sum of the
limits the limits of is the limit of
this term is Delta X approaches 0 plus
the limit of this term as Delta X
approaches 0 now let's stop to think
what these things mean the limit of
Delta X approaching 0 of Delta Y divided
by Delta X is precisely the definition
of derivative in other words this term
here is just dy/dx and keep in mind
we've evaluated this at x equals x1
that's the point at which we're starting
now the fact that this is a constant and
we've already learned that the limit of
a constant as Delta X approaches 0 is
that constant this term here is also dy
DX evaluated at x equals x1 and of
course this term here is just the limit
of K as Delta X approaches zero and now
you see if we look at this since all we
have to do is observe that this term
appears on both sides of the equation
canceling or subtracting equals from
equals we wind up with the result that
the limit of K as Delta X approaches 0
is 0
and we're going to talk about more about
that pictorially and analytically in a
little while but from this result what
we do next I'm going to do now is go
back to our first statement here
remembering that Delta X is a nonzero
number I will simply multiply both sides
of this equation by Delta X and if I do
that what do I wind up with I wind up
with that Delta Y is dy DX evaluated at
x equals x1 times Delta X plus K Delta X
now if I keep in mind here that if I
take the slope at a particular point and
multiply that by the change in X that
that's precisely what we define to be
delta y-tan if I put this all together I
get what that Delta Y is equal to Delta
Y 10 plus K Delta X where the limit of K
as Delta X approaches 0 is 0 now you see
when we started this program and started
to talk at the beginning of our lecture
about approximations we did something
that was quite crude the crude part was
simply this what we had said was why
don't we compute Delta Y by computing
Delta Y 10 instead in other words this
is a very easy thing to compute it's
just the derivative multiplied by a
change in X this is a very simple thing
to compute and we'll use that as an
approximation for the thing that we
really want which is Delta Y the
question that we deliberately overlooked
at this point was how big was the error
when you do this and what we discovered
was something very interesting and by
the way maybe something which teaches us
why the analysis is better than the
picture even though the picture is
easier to visualize you see we knew
intuitively that as you picked a smaller
neighborhood of the point of tangency
the tangent line became a better and
better approximation to the curve itself
this boxed-in result tells us much more
than that what this tells us is look at
if this trim by itself became small as
Delta X approach zero this would still
say the same thing
this says much more than that you see
what this says is a much this is very
very profound as Delta X approaches 0 as
Delta X approaches 0 K is also
approaching 0 in other words the term K
times Delta X seems to be approaching 0
much more rapidly than Delta X itself
that by the way in as simple a way as I
know how defines what an infinitesimal
is see K times Delta X is is called an
infinitesimal because it goes to 0
faster than Delta X itself in other
words anything that approaches 0 faster
than Delta X itself approaches 0 is
called an infinitesimal with respect to
Delta X now I'm not going to go into a
long philosophical discussion about that
rather I'm going to let the actions
speak louder than the words and try to
show why this is such a crucial idea in
other words again let me emphasize that
what's crucial here is not so much that
the error goes to 0 is that the error
goes to 0 much faster than Delta X goes
to 0 see what is the error the error is
K times Delta X that's the difference
between these two things again if you
want to see what this thing means
pictorially and I wish I knew a better
way of doing this but I don't notice
that K times Delta X was defined to be
the difference between Delta Y and Delta
Y 10 in other words since this length
here is Delta Y 10 and since this entire
length would be called Delta Y again the
accented line this length here is K
times Delta X and what does it mean to
say that K approaches zero as Delta X
approaches zero what it means is this
it means that not only does this
vertical difference get small as Delta X
goes to zero but more importantly it
means that this vertical distance gets
small very rapidly compared to how Delta
X gets small now how can I prove that
well I'm not even going to try to prove
that what I'm going to just try to do is
to have you see from the picture what's
happening here see here's a fairly large
Delta X and the difference between Delta
Y and Delta Y 10 for that large X is is
this length over here now suppose we
take a smaller Delta X in other words
let's take Delta X to be this length
over here notice that the length of
Delta X here is still quite significant
I think if you look at this you can see
it's a fairly significant length on the
other hand notice what the difference
between delta y and delta y-tan is now
it's just this little tiny thing over
here in other words notice that as Delta
X gets small ratio wise as Delta X gets
small the vertical difference between
the tangent line and the curve is
getting small at a much faster rate now
of course the question is why is that so
important and the answer will always
come back to our old friend of zero over
zero in general if you tell a person
that the numerator of a fraction is
small he jumps to the conclusion that
the size of the fraction must be small
but you see the trouble is when the
denominator is also small then we cannot
conclude that the fraction itself is
small and therefore in trying to cancel
out a trim as being insignificant when
we're dealing with something like this
it is no longer enough to say but the
numerator is going to zero let me jump
ahead to the topic that will be covered
in our next lecture just to use this as
an insight as to what we have to see and
what's going on over here
let me just show you what I mean by this
let's go back to our recipe which says
Delta Y is this thing over here where
what this is important to put in here
the limit of K as Delta X approaches 0
is zero now all we're going to do is
something like this let's suppose we're
dealing in the situation where Y and X
happen to be function say of T as well
some third variable T and we really want
to find is dy DT you see what we'd be
tempted to do is simply say what let's
divide through by delta T we do this we
divide through by delta T then we take
the limit of this thing as delta T
approaches zero now what happens as
delta T approaches zero
this is a sum the limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits each of the terms in
the sum is a product and the limit of a
product is the product of the limits so
working out the regular limit theorems
this is what the limit delta T
approaches 0 dy DX evaluated x equals x1
times the limit of Delta X divided by
delta T as delta T approaches 0 plus the
limit of K as delta T approaches 0 times
the limit of Delta X divided by delta T
as delta T approaches 0 now if we
remember what this thing here means this
is just by definition dy DT for the sake
of brevity I'll leave out subscripts now
but we'll just talk about this this is a
constant this is a constant and the
limit of a constant as delta T
approaches 0 is just that constant which
I'll call dy/dx it's understood this is
evaluated at x equals x1 by definition
the limit of Delta X divided by delta T
as delta T approaches 0
that's called DX DT now we come to this
term over here and here's the key point
many people say well as delta T goes to
0 so does Delta X that makes the
numerator here 0 and that makes the
whole fraction 0 but the point is that's
not true what is true he
is that both the numerator and
denominator are going to zero this does
not make this zero but rather it makes
it what DX DT that's the definition of
DX DT the important point is what that
as delta T approaches zero so that's
Delta X and what property does K have K
has the property that the limit of K as
Delta X approaches 0 is zero itself in
other words the topic that we'll be
talking about in our next lecture
concerns this recipe and in the
development of this recipe the reason
that the error term drops out is not
because the numerator of this term was
small it was because the number
multiplying this limit happened to be
zero now we will talk about that in more
detail next time but the message I want
you to see for right now is how we get
hung up on this zero over zero bit and
why we must always be careful in how we
handle something like this now by the
way there is something rather
interesting that does happen over here
if you look at this thing you get the
feeling that it's almost as if you could
cancel a common factor from both the
numerator and the denominator we have to
be very very careful and I would like to
introduce the language which we'll be
reading in the text in this assignment
called differentials now and what that
means is simply this notice that dy/dx
is one symbol it is not dy / DX because
these things have not been defined
separately in other words you can't just
operate with symbols the way you might
like to here's an interesting little
aside that you may find entertaining if
it has no other value at all you're the
idea of being told that you can cancel
common factors from both numerator and
denominator the uninitiated may say you
know here's a six and here's a six I'll
cancel them out now this is not what
cancellation really meant even though
you had the same number both upstairs
and downstairs
this is not
we meant by cancellation yet notice that
you happen to by accident get the right
answer in this particular case you see
if you do cancel this this does happen
to be one-fourth just for your own did
this lecture has been going on and kind
of a dull way for you just in case you'd
like some comic relief there are a few
other examples that work the same way
and you can amaze your friends the next
party with them
I mean 19 over 95 happens to be one
fifth twenty-six over sixty-five happens
to be two-fifths and I think there's one
more 49 over 98 happens to be four
eighths but these I believe are the only
four fractions that this works for in
other words the mere fact that it looks
like something is going to work is no
guarantee that you can do these things
without running into trouble on the
other hand it's fair to assume that the
men who invented differential calculus
must have been clever enough not to have
invented a symbolism that would have
gotten us into trouble that by the way
is a big assumption to make if they must
have been clever enough we will find in
places during our course that this was
not always the case
the point is this though that when you
write dy/dx
in this way if it were not going to be
somehow identifiable with a quotient
such as dy / DX the chances are we would
never have invented this notation in the
first place and so what I'd like to just
point out briefly now is the following
can we in fact we should how shall we
let's put it this way
how shall we define separate symbols dy
and DX so that when we write down dy DX
it will make no difference whether you
think of this as being the derivative or
whether you think of it as being the
quotient of two numbers and by the way
you see the answer to this question will
not be that difficult if we stop to
think for just a moment over here namely
let's go we've already answered this
question except that we haven't
concentrated on the fact that we solved
the problem so let's go back to this
line L again
what is the slope of the line L on the
one hand we've learned that slope is the
derivative dy/dx on the other hand just
by looking at this little accentuated
triangle here the slope of the line L is
also given by Delta Y 10 divided by
Delta X and now one of the best ways to
define dy and DX separately it would
seem to me is what notice that this
number divided by this number yields the
symbol dy/dx therefore why not define
this number define this number to be dy
and define this number to be DX in other
words the symbol DX will just be a fancy
name for Delta X on the other hand the
symbol dy will not be a fancy name for
Delta Y in fact let's emphasize that
it's not equal to Delta Y it is equal to
Delta Y 10 in other words if I allow dy
to stand for Delta Y 10 and DX to stand
for Delta X I can now treat dy DX as if
it were what dy / DX well that's easy to
show in terms of an example just
mechanically remember given y equals x
cubed we've already found what that
dy/dx is 3x squared this thing
practically begs to be treated like a
fraction we would like to be able to say
hey if this divided by this is this why
isn't this equal to this times this in
other words why isn't dy equal to 3x
squared DX and the answer is that since
we've identified or defined
dy to be delta y-tan and since we've
defined DX to be Delta X and since we
already know that this recipe is correct
it means in particular that we can now
write things
like this without having to worry about
whether it's proper or not now in later
lectures this is going to play a very
important role this is what is known as
the language of differentials and
differentials are the backbone of both
differential and integral calculus but
the thing that I want you to really get
into our minds today is the basic
overall recipe and I've taken the
liberty of boxing this off over here
that I want you to practice with
approximations I want you to think
carefully about how you can get quick
approximations I don't want you to come
away with the feeling that the
approximation is what was important what
was important was what that the change
in Y the true Delta Y is dy/dx times
Delta X plus K Delta X where the limit
of K as Delta X approaches 0 is 0 ok and
by the way again
most books write this this way I prefer
that we emphasize that the derivative is
evaluated or taken at a particular value
of x and finally what I'd like to point
out is that we're again and we've done
this many many times whereas the
language we're used to in terms of
intuition is geometry that these results
make perfectly good sense without
reference to any diagram at all in other
words then the same result stated in
analytic language simply says this if f
is a function of X and is differentiable
when x equals x1 then f of x1 plus Delta
X minus f of x1
you see that's geometrically what
corresponds to your Delta Y that's F
prime of x1 times Delta X plus K Delta X
where the limit of K as Delta X
approaches 0 is 0 now this these two
recipes summarize precisely what it is
that we are interested in when we deal
with the subject called infinitesimals
as I said before and I can't emphasize
strongly enough when it comes time to
make approximations we will find better
ways of getting approximations than by
the method known as differentials and
delta y-tan what is crucial is that you
use the language of approximations
enough so you can see pictorially what's
going on and then cement down the final
recipe which i've boxed in here this
will be the building block as we shall
see next time in the lecture which
develops the derivative of composite
functions but more about that next time
and until next time goodbye funding for
the publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and Paul
Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate